the moment a missile hit a crowded
shopping center in kremen chuck this new
footage is from a security camera about
a hundred meters away
slowed down it appears to show a 1960s
medium-range cruise missile originally
designed to attack aircraft carriers and
relatively inaccurate
the new video was shared by president
zielenski who's called the strike an act
of russian state terrorism
a russian missile hit this location
precisely deliberately it's clear that
such were the orders given
it's clear that russian killers received
those exact coordinates for this missile
they wanted to kill as many people as
possible in a peaceful city in an
ordinary shopping mall this video shows
a park next to an industrial complex
near the shopping mall
the pair you see are reacting to the
missile strike
then this
a second missile has hit a factory
this is the same moment
you can see the shock wave as debris
lands on the water
russian officials claimed a strike on a
weapons depot detonated ammunition
setting the shopping center on fire
ukraine says there was no depot in the
area
on wednesday addressing crowds in the
vatican pope francis referred to the
deadly strike
porto union
every day in my heart i carry deer
martyred ukraine which continues to be
flagellated by barbarous attacks like
the one that hit the shopping center in
cremenchuk i pray that this mad wall
in southern ukraine several people were
killed in an attack on a residential
building the mayor here says this was
the work of a russian x-55 cruise
missile russia claims it's destroyed a
training base for foreign mercenaries
near the city
for his part president zielenski is now
urging the united nations to visit the
destroyed shopping center in cremenchuk
to establish the facts
nadeem baba al-jazeera